hey guys Ryan right here so today I'm
gonna be checking out the trailer for
The Legend of Tarzan the teaser trailer
number one I don't know much about this
film but I wanted to mention that right
now I'm actually in New York I'm
visiting my family this is my last day
with my family so I don't have time to
edit and provide a trailer review for
you guys so that trailer review for
whatever I'm gonna bout to watch that
will be up on Sunday cuz I'll be back
home so once so today I'm just gonna
check out the trailer and you'll get a
reaction from me and then on Sunday keep
a look out for the actual trailer review
let's do this one our brothers good
company work with you guys
the jungle consumes everything
through some Hill like a king kong's
like the wounded
Prince of the week
beautifully shot and that looks pretty
good
it's not to be an evil spirit
a ghost in the tree
no man ever started this back oh [ __ ]
he's in this movie Margot Robbie
I was hoping
Sam Jackson
but the [ __ ]
Tarzan looks beautiful fight amongst
Apes
I see the district hold of the ape king
of the jungle Tarzan
why they why they show that last scene
where he's out of the jungle I wonder
how the movies gonna play out my quick
10-second review would be it looks epic
it's shot beautifully
I love the actors that are in this film
I feel like there's gonna be a lot of
great things tonally I'm a little bit
confused especially that one show where
Sam Jackson's like whipping out those
guns I don't know it some look like a
different film to me from that one shot
okay I don't have time to go into this
keep a lookout for Sunday's trailer
review if you're new to the channel
subscribe to the reel rejects become a
rejected a yeah yeah and keep a lookout
for I keep saying this keep a lookout
for the trailer review on Sunday where
I'll be talking more in depth about The
Legend of Tarzan and my feelings and
thoughts my speculation it's funny how a
review trailers now because there was a
time where I was like can you even
review a trailer other than this is what
I'm anticipating and this is what it
looks like because at the end of the day
the movie could be totally different and
the movie should be judged by the movie
not the trailer this video will be worth
your time